it's time for roses and Rosie hi it's
January
you guys today roses and roses roses and
cafe I just pulled a wine glass of
coffee out of my lap yes we need coffee
because we are starting a new year Happy
New Year everybody and happy new season
of The Bachelor let's get to work
I just came back from vacation so I'm
exhausted and I needed some coffee and
we're filming this early in the morning
and frankly drinking that early in the
morning is even outside of my comfort
zone let's keep our boundaries you know
because we're not the women on The
Bachelor who don't have boundaries which
is why I love this show so Ari says this
is the most important race of my life
please let me know what you guys thought
of the premiere by the way leave your
thoughts in the comments and message me
on social media as many of you did
because there was some bachelor drama
over the holiday to do with Peter and
Ari and I was on vacation so there you
have it everybody's got to take a break
anyways we cut to five years ago and
Emily's like I'm sorry I'm sorry
is it new late now to say sorry
yes Emily
cuz it's Jan you ah Frankie we get it re
was on Emily made her season of The
Bachelorette we were relived it all we
don't need to talk about it anymore
okay we know who he is Ari's in real
estate now then we meet lots of the
women with their intro packages but the
thing is we met lots of them on the
countdown to re already so P hey in 2018
we don't have time to rewind we can only
fast-forward moving forward you know to
thank you these are our thoughts what
are you the new year's resolutions mine
include working out something different
mmm okay this is by the way straight
espresso it's five shots and I've
already had four 2018 so then we need
someone new who we didn't meet on the
countdown crystal crystal is a fitness
coach we see her filming what I'm
assuming are her YouTube videos she's
open she's vulnerable I don't know what
to think of crystal yet because she
seems very genuine I'm coming in with
the guards off my heart how have you not
found that piece yet how have you not
found love it's a good question I asked
it to Ari to and I like that his answer
was consistent with me and with Chris
which was just it just didn't happen
meeting 30 new girls
okay so we have Caroline she gets out a
limo first with an Austin market joke
she's roasting available be off the
market love it and then we have single
mom Chelsea we'll get into her we have
Siena I think who likes elephants and
she had cufflinks for him and said don't
forget me I thought that was cute house
cute that was nice good mix of genuine
and like a little wild nothing too crazy
although we did have the spray tan woman
who says that she owns a spray tan
business
I see a lot of okay why and then there
was a gal who asked Aria to smell her
armpits and I did not put on deodorant
today yeah he's so amazing okay what
else happened oh we had we had single
mom Chelsea so after the limo entrances
are over she sweeps right in to grab re
right away and Ari's like I like her
because she didn't have to tell me
everything right away and she's
mysterious leaving me wanting a little
bit more I have to say I would find that
balance so difficult time let's show you
guys because it's like oh you didn't
open up a soon enough so I'm sending you
home but oh don't tell me everything
right away and oh I get like 30 seconds
with you one night one it's difficult
so round of applause for effort cheers
to all these women for the effort huh
2018 is about effort I actually got a
list of goals for the new year and I'm
gonna try to stick to them and help you
all due to writing things down helps us
manifest like when Ari wrote that
journal did you read it I did it anyway
we're not in the past not in the past so
Ari has his first kiss and this woman
says that his lips are like the softest
ever next time I see Ari I gotta ask him
what lip products are you using he told
me the secrets to a good kiss include
having good breath and that's a great
tip but like what chapstick or you want
is it Burt's Bees is it classic
chapstick is it Vaseline we've gotta
know none of this is product placement I
wish that I could do that okay so then
there's Jenna she is wild she touches
are his feet
no that would be a no for me you guys my
feet sweat when I get nervous and I
would not want anyone to touch my feet
on the first date so good for Ari for
putting up with that and Ari did a great
job all night of sort of like playfully
calling people out you know he's like
Jana is wild and by wild I think he
meant completely
even rock or off a rocker I mean she was
like all over the place and he was like
I don't know what she does for a living
she and social media
ashiya pedicurist but he keeps Jenna
around in the rose ceremony because we
need women like Jennifer good TV right
tia is from Weiner Arkansas we met her
before and she gave Ari a little Weiner
yeah please tell me you don't already
have a little Weiner I do not have this
so think about it my concern is that he
has a lot of girls up to something
there's the same number of women every
season come on
get together girl and then we need the
beca's drink every time someone on the
show has the same name of someone else
mmm there's gonna be a lot of bad guys
and a lot of Lawrence oh great I'm
Lauren drinking through all the Lauren's
it's gonna be really inconvenient for me
all season it's a gratitude rock okay
okay
just being Ben that was smart everyone
was jealous of her idea and the bad guys
let's discuss them so Becca number one
comes in in a classic car and she's like
I might be young but I can appreciate
the classic her age is gonna become an
issue but she's 22 and she seems really
mature and I like her so let it go
also that mchale girl who kind of
one-upped Becca by showing up in a
racecar he's 23 so what difference does
a year make why are we not gonna give
McHale the same hard time I don't know
Ari told me at the end of the day it's
just about maturity and who the person
is and I agree I think life experiences
make you who you are you can be 55 and
act like a 12 year old move to Los
Angeles you'll meet those people Oh
at one point a woman said the older that
men get the better-looking they get so
true this does make me sad I don't
disagree but let's say the same thing
about women okay how about the older
women get the better-looking we are why
do we criticize women for how old they
look let's let that go
thank you everybody okay let's talk
about Chelsea single moms Chelsea is she
going to be a villain it seems is she
just misunderstood because she's just
trying to get her time in
maybe she got the first-impression rose
what did you guys think controversial
she threw some shade at the other ladies
throw a little shade at mikkel for
example and she went in bump-bump-bump
to get a second slot of time with re
which on night one what a cardinal sin
by Chelsea and she had a quite a
luscious kiss with Arie we're seeing
that kissing van that come out re did
not disappoint on the kissing Becca also
asked all right what are three things
that make you exciting to be alive three
things like yeah I think one of them was
pizza it's a tough question from Beck's
and she for sure had her answers ready
to go I don't know about that I mean
it's one of those things where I feeI I
have to be honest I feel like it's like
oh I'm trying to be really in depth with
this question but it's such a strange
big question when you first meet someone
that it feels a little I don't know
whatever so and then Becca who had re
proposed to her got the first rose at
the rose ceremony so I think even if
that was edited to be out of order that
means that we should take some
significance with Becca because re day
for the first rose having our I proposed
to her sounded crazy on paper like we
get press releases for this stuff and I
thought this sounds crazy but in real
life it I thought it was cute Becca
seems cool and genuine and I thought
that they had a good conversation that
night so guys night one let's talk about
our standouts I mean these nights are so
long the women who are sent home we will
not remember and they are crying as the
Sun is coming out because they've been
there for hours night one I liked both
of the Becca's I'm in cute little young
Becca looks like a little Audrey Hepburn
I liked them my girl s like a choker
looks love the women's fashions you know
I mean wow who else did rent the runway
for this night probably a lot of Sobek
guys were good Krystal I'm interested to
watch Chelsea I'm very interested to
watch and Jenna what a gal let me know
you guys liked from night one let me
know what you thought of re on night one
did he rev up your engine or did he
crash and burn
did he have you putting your foot on the
gas or did he have you pumping the
brakes did it wasn't a complete and
total wreck or gonna get first place
that's all the car funds I have
everybody overall I thought re came
across very genuine which I liked and I
think that we're gonna see him get more
into it I think he was a little nervous
again in kind of an adorable way and I
think he has good women I think these
women seem overall to be pretty smart we
didn't have any like super psychos on
night one so happy new year everyone
happy 2018 and happy January wow I
didn't drink any of my coffee here we go
new year new me in January
Wow baby I will make sure to iet and the
Facebook ID subscribe to us on YouTube
my coffee really hit me guys will be
here every Tuesday by the way doing rows
and rows a of course often with rows a
in the future so please tune in and let
me know your thoughts I love to hear
them and I love you guys bye
[Music]